Welcome to week one in the Robotic Vision
Project. My name is Liam O'Sullivan and I'll
be your guide for the next seven weeks as
to how to complete the Robotic Vision Project.
The first one to six weeks, you'll be getting
a picture of this Robotic Vision worksheet
into MATLAB and then classifying the 2D objects
which exist on this page, into a particular
colour, shape and size. This forms the input
to an optional seventh week where you can
take a robotic arm that you've created, put
it on the Robotic Vision worksheet and then
actuate to a particular 2D object. Let's take
a look now in MATLAB at what the output of
the Robotic Vision Project will be.
Alright, so we're in MATLAB here and we're
looking at the output of the project through
weeks one through six, so if we look at this
image here, we can see our Robotic Vision
worksheet, so you guys are going to have to
download this worksheet, which is in PDF format
and print it out, then we'll take a photo
of it using either our mobile phone camera
or a webcam and then we'll import it into
MATLAB and then apply some image processing
techniques to try and find the 2D position
of the coloured shapes on this page.
Now you might be saying to yourself, "Okay
why do I have to bother about image processing,
I could just get out a ruler and then measure
all the 2D positions of the objects on this
page." Well you could do that, there's nothing
stopping you from doing that; however what
happens if we change the configuration of
these shapes?
You know we could move these shapes into any
position on the page and then you would have
to re-measure the position of where they ended
up.
A smarter and better way would be to rely
on image processing, so write some computer
vision code that allows you to find the 2D
position of the objects, no matter what configuration
they are in. So we could change it and then
it would take simply a click of a button and
we could find the position of these objects.
Okay, so that's the goal of the project and what we'll be working on through weeks one through six.